[Music]
hi everyone my name is ian lake hi i'm
denny osan piada and i'm been vice and
here we're here to talk about a little
thing called navigation now what what is
navigation um if you're here for Google
Maps you're not in the right talk
because today we'll be talking
specifically about the jetpack
navigation component now when we say
component what does that actually mean
well let's look at what the mission
statement for jetpack navigation
actually is so it's a suite of libraries
tooling and guidance that provide a
robust navigation framework for in-app
navigation so a very specific goal is
kind of that in-app nation that
navigation between screens and provide
more than just the libraries but also
tooling and guidance to go along with
that so I think it's best to kind of
explain navigation with a sample app so
here we're going to build a trivia app
and because I'm a Googler and of course
has chat built in so we have a chat list
size all of your conversations and then
of course a chat fragment which will
actually have the actual conversation
itself and of course a profile and all
these will be available via a navigation
drawer on our main activity so we chose
fragments here because they provide a
really good integration with other
architecture components like view models
and life cycle and to kind of actually
make this all work we're putting all of
these fragments in a now host fragment
so this is the thing that navigation
provides for you which is basically the
container where as we swap between these
different screens in our app the now
host fragment is what's actually going
to be that container in your layout so
what do we actually need to build out
this sample app and it's 40 minute talk
so we're gonna go fast but we have a
navigation graph itself so this is kind
of the map of your app and it has four
fragment destinations are four screens
then of course we're gonna have a menu
and
for setting up our side navigation our
navigation view with what items we want
in that list but of course we have our
layout for our our activity which is
going to have a drawer layout for our
side nav a toolbar for our top app bar
and then our nav shows fragment which is
actually going to be the main content of
our app and then lastly we just need an
activity to kind of tie all those things
together so what does this actually look
like first we'll start with the graph
now we want a deep integration in the
tooling so in Android studio Android
studio 3.4 and 3.5 we have a navigation
editor so besides being able to do
things in XML and also programmatically
if you're up for that you also get a
visual editor where we can actually see
the structure of our whole app here you
know with all the pieces and all the
links between each one so for example
between the chat list and the chat next
for our menu it's all very kind of basic
stuff IDs icons and titles for each one
but the important part here is we'll use
the same IDs as we put on in our
navigation graph and this is what will
that navigation kind of tie these things
together automatically now of course for
our actual layout we've stripped out a
few layout widths and Heights so don't
try and compile this but that's all the
important bits specifically has one
important bit which is the actual
Navajos fragment itself so here we'll
just put it directly in our layout and a
post fragment and here's where we'll
actually use that app Navagraha that to
the graph that we created in our xml
then took up our navigation view for
that side nav we'll just attach the same
menu that we built here it's now what
really is just the activity that binds
all these things together so we made it
really easy from anywhere in your
activity as well as anywhere in a
fragment as well as any view within that
whole hierarchy to get an instance of
your nav controller so call an extension
or fine nav controller with just the ID
of your naff host fragment of course if
you're using the java programming
language
then you'll be able to use a static
method to do the exact same thing so
once we have this nav controller right
this thing that is powering all of
navigation what do we actually do with
it well we can do a couple things one we
can set up our toolbar at the top and
what we'll do here is use our the app
bar configuration this is kind of that
figuring out what that top app bar is
supposed to do in the first place and
the first thing we want to do is make
sure that all of those top-level
destinations those three things in our
navigation view are all kind of at the
same visual hierarchy so we pass in the
list here and those are the ones that
won't show an up arrow right there all
at the same visual hierarchy level so we
want to make sure we tell navigation oh
these three destinations are important
then we're going to pass in the actual
drawer layout itself and this is the key
that says when you're on one of those
top-level destinations instead of
showing no icon at all you want to show
that hamburger icon so that users know
that they can pull out the drawer and
then with that app bar configuration set
up all we call is set up with nav
controller another call an extension on
the toolbar here and now as we navigate
between screens of our app we're
automatically updating the title in the
toolbar we're automatically changing the
icon and there's nothing else we need to
do to hook up to get the correct up
behavior to get the correct label it's
all kind of built into this
functionality because we've set up our
app bar configuration correctly
similarly for our navigation view it's
the same type of thing we have with just
another set up with nav controller now
whenever you click on something in your
side nav it's automatically gonna go to
the right screen because we use that
same ID in the menu and the navigation
graph similarly the selected item is
always going to stay in sync with where
you're at in the graph so now we don't
need to focus on anything else
but we built a lot of things right it
was like we just never need to touch our
activity again but how do we actually
put this all together well it started
with the common library and this is
where I actually have the runtime
equivalent of navigation graphs and all
the kind of base components and on top
of that is the actual navigation runtime
library so this is kind of that thing
that provides the actual nav controller
itself but on top of that we realize
like okay well that's kind of the core
pieces but we want to build a few things
so you know a lot of people do use
fragments they are probably one of the
most popular api's not from a popularity
but from a usage perspective so we
wanted something out of the box and
especially that integration with other
architecture components was really
important so we have the Navajos
fragment and the ability to use fragment
destinations in a navigation fragment
library similarly if you're using those
material components like toolbars and
other things then we have a navigation
UI which is what provides the app bar
configuration and all these set up with
nav controller items these top two items
are totally optional if you want to go
off the rails and do something totally
different we do support all of that as
well just using navigation runtime and
of course because it's 2019 of course we
have KTX versions of all of these so
Colin extensions for all of these things
as well as a Colin DSL for building
navigation graphs and many other
features if you're using Colin now we
talked a little bit about the library
side and saw the navigation editor but
we also have more tooling integration as
well so being able to integrate in with
manifest merger so you don't have to
write intent filters for deep links we
can build that for you
out of the deep links you put in your
navigation graph similarly we also have
a safe args Gradle plugin which we'll
talk about more in detail that really
makes it easy to move between
destinations and it types
and of course we also talked about the
guidance side of things so one of the
things that was really for us is to not
just throw a library over the wall but
instead really talk to our internal
design teams and other teams outside of
Google say what actually works for
developers how can we make a consistent
experience across everyone and that
really came up with a lot of the
guidance and a lot of the documentation
that we provide so we have quite a few
pages on developer.android.com that
really go into the details on how not
only how to use navigation but also some
of the why and some of the reasonings
behind things and the way to really kind
of set it up in a consistent way across
every app and also we have worked with
dev rel and other organizations to make
sure that you have good getting started
points with our code lab now the
documentation was a really big focus for
the navigation stable released last
month but it also is a big focus for our
navigation 2.1 release which is in alpha
right now one of the things in there was
dialog destinations so in addition to
using full screen fragments now you can
use a dialog destination and in then you
can navigate to a dialog so this is
supported out of the box by nav host
fragment just like fragment destinations
that allows you to use all the same
actions and arguments as you would for
any other kind of destination so what
does this look like in code well instead
of just using the fragment tag for a
fragment now we can use a dialogue tag
for a dialogue oh that's pretty easy
right same type of things are supported
so if you have arguments like for
example here we have an error message
for our error dialog fragment those all
still work just like any other
destination
another feature that we were really
excited about for navigation 2.1 was
integration with view models now view
models are an architecture component
about saving data across configuration
changes and with the new safe state view
models even saving things across process
death and Recreation but we realized
there was something that needed to
happen in between the activity scope ie
the entire app as well as just the
individual fragment level so now you can
actually scope things to a navigation
graph so let's take a look at what that
looks like here's our four destinations
that we add and now we want to add an
onboarding flow right and so our our
onboarding Florez welcome set up and
find friends because of course we got a
connect to all of our friends with a
totally incompatible proprietary api but
for these things we want to share data
between these fragments so by
encapsulating this in an onboarding
graph a nested graph now we actually had
the way of attaching information at the
graph level rather than just at the
destination level so what does this look
like well we can just use a bi nav view
models Kotlin property delegate to
actually get an instance of our
onboarding view model from any one of
the destinations within that graph now
of course there's a static method for
Java users as well so it totally works
on both and then we can do whatever we
want so in this case when we set up is
complete we save the user ID into our
view model that allows say our next
fragment to then get an instance of that
exact same view model even if you've
done configuration changes across things
and then extract that information out of
it or maybe do something more useful
because this is a toy example for slides
now these are all kind of based on a lot
of what we built for navigation Stables
release and one of the things I was most
excited for was safe arts and to talk
more about
who's Danny thanks Ian alright so like
Ian mentioned save argh is a great Oh
plug-in that basically complements the
navigation library
it basically grabs your navigation file
analyzes them and generates some code
for you to use in your application to
help you safely pass arguments and
navigate to valid destinations now you
might be wondering why do we create a
safe arc or why would why would you even
use a farts after all it's an optional
plugin but we highly recommend that you
use it the main reason is that some of
the checks that are perform at runtime
now get to be done at compile time so
this means you get to do faster
iteration as you work with your
navigation graph now because you
generate code it means you can leverage
some of the affixing tools in Android
studio for example autocomplete will
kick in when you're trying to use it and
again because it generates code it means
it transforms your types in your
navigation arguments to actual types in
the language system let's take a look at
it and how to use it and the kind of
code it generates we're back to the
application we've got a new requirement
or bosses as usual give us more work
this time when we click on our thumbnail
on one of the chat lists we get to go to
a profile so now we have two
destinations that we can get from our
chat list if we take a look at how we
have the finer chat list destination as
usual you have you defying the fragment
that it uses and the to test
arrows that come out of it are the two
actions that we have and these are the
two destinations that you will use to
get out of it
now we're on our satellite meaning we're
trying to hook things together we're
implemented our profile image click
listener we have enough controller and
usually you will navigate using your
action this is how you will do a normal
navigation usually without Seifert's but
we save arcs instead you will use the
generated code you would use this class
called Shapley's Franklin directions
we'll see we'll see it in a bit but the
cool thing here is as you're trying to
use it the idea kicks in and you
actually have autocomplete on the ballot
actions that you can take from this
destination now what does safe are
actually generates well for each
destination will generate I directions
class and this class basically has
functions for the ballot actions that
you can take these functions also
actually have parameters and these
parameters are based on the arguments
that you have in your action and if they
have default values they all show here
as default value as you can see and this
is how we make sure that by calling this
function and passing the right
parameters you will be able to receive
them on the other side correctly safer
also generates a second set of classes
which we call the arts classes we
navigate it now to the profile frontmen
and we want to parse the arguments we
would use what we call the profile
fragment arts I generate a class by the
say parks and this is just a better
class that contains your actual types of
your arguments but as you can see he has
teeth these two methods to bundle from
Mongo and you will use these methods to
actually you know get the arts out but
using this method is how we basically
take what their responsibility from you
from using bundles even better if you're
using codling we also have this
extension lacy function alright by now
marks which helps you get those arts and
start assessing those data that that are
pretty quickly now you might have
noticed that the generator code is in
Kotlin and that's because safe arts will
actually generate both Java
and coupling code and some people were
pretty excited about it they stopped
pressing the shift button and yeah now
to use the plugin you just go to your
builder Gradle apply the plug-in with
the ID and using this ID will generate
the will generate the Java code but
using the cutting version of the IDE
will generate the cut link code pretty
straightforward now why did we decided
to generate codling well there's two
main benefits one is build performance
if you have a coupling only app then
generate the cutting code that means you
don't have big sources and the second is
that we get to use automatic convict
code in the java version of the
generator code we have builders but in
the Kotlin inversion we have data
classes with primary constructor that
you can use name arguments and default
arguments so that's pretty nice because
their data classes you also have things
like copy hash code and those kind of
things for your arguments now whether
the plugin generates Cottenham or java
code it doesn't mean a lot if we don't
support a lot of types so we started
supporting the pragmatic side and as we
got closer through stable we were we
were able to add support for possible
serializable and even so if you have
active actions that have arguments of
that are personal items you can use
those with the new documentation we
actually have a pretty table with all of
this information you can look up there
how the syntax looks whether it supports
the file default values are not notable
and things like that
Seifert's is pretty good when you're
trying to work with a tightly coupled
broth but sometimes you might need to
have a more couple navigation graph and
Ben here will talk to you a little bit
more about that thank you
modernizing applications has become
increasingly important especially since
we last year announced the Android app
bundle and this year with dynamic
feature modules being get generally
available we will see a lot more
applications that will be modularized
this not only reflects to your
application while you develop it but
that allows you with dynamic feature
modules to actually ship parts of the
application to your users a couple of
the benefits there on modularization
during development are that you can cut
down your build times by creating
distinct modules also you can separate
the concerns within the image and within
those separation of concerns also is
around navigation and navigation library
supports modularization so let's talk a
little bit about how you can split up
your graph while you break up your
application into distinct modules we saw
this graph grow over this presentation
and we have a couple of you look at the
design editor here we have a home and
error our home graph which is the which
also has the arrow dialogue we have a
chat list we have the chat and we have
the profile as well also we have a
nested graph in here we can break this
up in multiple in multiple ways what we
are doing here is we're breaking up this
graph into several distinct libraries we
will still continue to have one
application module we will have a home
module a chat and a profile we'll just
take that away and put it into a
distinct graph in a distinct library
module as well so if you take a look at
this for these navigation file it's
really really tricky to see what's going
on here and this is already a very
simplified example if you have a real
world app you can keep on scrolling with
these for a long time so what we do
instead is we just break it up into the
modules we take out the relevant source
or the relevant destinations and put
those into the files where they are
going to be used and we do that for each
of the modules that we recruit that we
are creating as
see each of that has a start destination
that we're able to jump into and then we
include these in the graph that we are
hosting in the application itself so all
the modules that we have created can be
included in that the way this works is
using the include tag that has been
around since we launched navigation and
you just simply include the graphs that
you we have it extracted out here this
goes alongside each other in navigation
destination that already exists so you
can have nested graphs or any other
target any other destination in here
this is really cool when you have when
you have independent graphs and you want
to navigate between those that's great
but what if you want to move from one
graph to another our chat app has grown
so we have a profile fragment but also
well we want to have friends in the app
so we want to make sure that we have the
friend list there as well and since you
can navigate from the profile to the
friend list we have that in the profile
graph so what you want to do is what you
can do here with IDs is you can simply
reference the chat graph and the start
destination here but I will only lead us
so far actually what we would like to
have is we want to go straight if
somebody if we click on the on a friend
list what we want to do is we want to go
straight to the chat fragment being able
to chat directly with a friend rather
than going to the chat list first and
I'm jumping in there with IDs like I
said it's not only possible to jump
directly to the start destination of the
graph and that's why with navigation 2.1
we have enabled navigation by your eyes
so you can use deep links to navigate
directly to destinations even across
graph boundaries how this works is you
remove your ID and declare deep link in
here with a URI it can host the
parameter for the for a user ID so you
can jump directly into the user fragment
and start chatting with your friends
right away
so you're not longer have to hold on to
IDs you no longer in the modularize that
would have to have them in a shared
space instead of that you have your your
eyes that you can share across the
application and within the friendless
fragment what we would M would do as we
simply build up the URI and navigate to
our destination another problem that
comes as we came across is when you
navigate not within an app that has
library modules but one that has dynamic
feature modules the question out here is
where are we going with this libraries
can so as you can see the dynamic
feature modules have a bit of a
different way that the dependencies are
on one another so they can't depend on
the app and it's really tricky to
navigate between those features when it
comes to modules that are not on device
in particular dynamic feature modules
can be installed initially or can be
downloaded later on we've heard
questions around this over the past year
and we thought about it and we are we
have started to work on a new library
that is extending the navigation library
that will allow you to intercept
navigating to separate destinations then
if the module that we're looking for is
not installed it will take care of all
the downloading for that provides you
with a couple of feet with a couple of
callbacks to either provide your own UI
while yet while it while it's
downloading or with a default safe
version for you to use as well and then
once the module is downloaded and ready
it will continue navigating if the
modules installed initially all of this
all what it does is it directs you
directly to your target destination we
just looked in a bit of the future what
we're what's in store for for navigation
and to talk a little bit more about the
bigger picture here let me know invite
back in
thanks Ben I'm really excited about the
dynamic feature navigation and looking
forward to seeing that later this year
but I want to talk a little bit more
generally about just where we're going
with navigation so I realized it took us
a while to get to that 1.0 stable
release but from now on what we're
trying to move towards is a much faster
iteration time so the time between the
first alpha and the first release 2 beta
2 RC 2 stable realize that not everyone
is happy using the latest latest alpha
release and sometimes a little bit of
that stability or at least the word
stable or the lack of the word alpha can
really help win over PM's who aren't as
familiar with what alpha means for
navigation so we're really trying to
focus on just a small set of features so
what we talked about today we're the
core the features in navigation 2.1 at
this point we're saying like no let's
cut it off here and let's go towards
beta and RC and stable now rather than
continuing to add features over and over
again but that doesn't mean that we're
not working on more things there's
certainly a lot more dynamic feature
navigator is one thing but we're also
really looking at your feedback so we
have and we use the issue tracker Google
comm extensively particularly for
navigation and all these counts here are
actually the number of stars that you
all have given for navigation features
and we can see we've done pretty good we
fixed we fixed a fair few of them some
of these are actually fixed in
navigation 2.1 based on your feedback
but there's still a few more to do and
you know if it's not in two point one
that's gonna be in 2.2 or 2.3 as we go
through things we realize some of these
things like multiple back stacks are
very highly requested and they do mean
that we also need to work on the
underlying libraries so for example that
one we should probably get that working
in fragments and then working in
navigation as well and that's certainly
bigger efforts but it's something that
we're dedicated to do and something that
we think that would be great to have out
to all of you in the near future so I'd
really like to continue if you have more
feature requests bug reports anything
please let us know if we can find an
issue for it already
we'll certainly happy to look at that
but your stars really do Drive the
future of navigation
[Music]